Новий керівник "Укрзалізниці" Володимир Жмак заявив, що наразі не бачить можливості та сенсу
залучати до співпраці іноземних фахівців, у тому числі й німецької залізничної компанії Deutsche Bahn.
Цим, по суті, він перекреслив меморандум про взаєморозуміння та стратегічне партнерство,
підписаний німцями та українцями у лютому цього року.
Головний аргумент нового керівника "Укрзалізниці" -
у Європі вантажні залізничні перевезення не є настільки життєво важливими, як в Україні.
DW зібрала факти про вантажоперевезення і залізницю в Німеччині.
Залізничний транспорт в Німеччині - найбільша в Європі залізнична мережа.
Експлуатаційна протяжність шляхів становить понад 33 з половиною тисяч кілометрів,
дві третини з них електрифіковані.
Головним залізничним оператором є концерн Deutsche Bahn AG, на якому лише в Німеччині
працюють понад 200 тисяч людей, ще понад 100 тисяч за кордоном.
Підприємство організоване як акціонерне товариство і перебуває у власності держави.
Торік залізниця Німеччини перевезла понад 2 з половиною мільярди пасажирів і 232 мільйонів тонн вантажів.
Оборот концерну склав 44 з половиною мільярди євро.
Під дахом Deutsche Bahn працює близько 600 дочірніх та асоційованих підприємств.
Найбільший оборот Deutsche Bahn робить на логістиці, пасажирських перевезеннях та інфраструктурі.
Вантажоперевезення - це лише один із сегментів.
Вантажні залізничні перевезення - DB Cargo - справді майже найслабша ланка німецької залізниці.
Нещодавно у DB Cargo змінилося керівництво. Нова очільниця поставила мету до середини 2020-их
зробити хронічно проблемні вантажні залізничні перевезення знову прибутковими.
Серед причин - брак персоналу, перевантажені колії, технічні несправності,
але головним чином ринкова ситуація. У загальній системі вантажоперевезень на залізницю припадає 18-20 відсотків.
Майже три чверті сумарного вантажотрафіку здійснюється автобанами.
Однак, фури шкідливі для довкілля. Тому німці у наступні роки хочуть зменшити частку вантажоперевезень автошляхами
і роблять ставку на екологічно чистіші локомотиви, що працюють здебільшого на електричному приводі.
Тому уряд ФРН ставить за мету стимулювати вантажні перевезення саме залізницею.
Перевезенням людей опікується не одне, а одразу декілька дочірніх підприємств Deutsche Bahn.
DB Regio відповідальне за регіональні сполучення, DB Ferhverkehr - за міжміські та DB Arriva - за міжнародні сполучення.
Найбільший оборот припадає на регіональні сполучення - майже 9 мільярдів євро.
А DB Arriva успішно оперує перевезеннями за межами Німеччини у 14 європейських країнах.
Щоправда, останніми роками німецьку залізницю часто критикують за непунктуальність.
Лише три чверті потягів минулого року прибували точно за розкладом, тобто з відхиленням менше 5 хвилин.
Сферу логістики на початку 2000-их німецька залізниця виділила в окремий напрямок,
заснувавши підприємство DB Schenker і відокремивши його від вантажних залізничних перевезень.
Нині DB Schenker - один з провідних перевізників вантажів у світі повітряним шляхом.
Тож, німецька залізниця, так би мовити, ще й "літає", а також возить вантажі наземним і морським транспортом.
Крім того, Schenker пропонує клієнтам спеціалізовані логістичні рішення:
від доставки надважких вантажів до розробки нафтових родовищ.
Залізнична інфраструктура поділена на три окремі компанії.
Одна відповідає за понад 7 тисяч вокзалів та інших залізничних будівель.
Друга - за колії. Третя - за енергомережі.
При цьому Deutsche Bahn отримує колосальні цільові субсидії від держави.
Приміром, лише у наступні 10 років німецька залізниця отримає понад 100 мільярдів євро від держави,
зокрема на впровадження екологічних стандартів на залізниці і модернізацію залізничних колій.